so you guys may have seen it this uh
this ufo report we've all
been waiting for it and a lot of people
said it was a dud pentagon report says
ufos can't be explained and this
admission is a big deal
it is a big deal it means they're coming
up right now and saying oh yeah you know
all those ufos people reported seeing
well they are real we've seen them too
and we have no idea what they are
so now it's just opened up the door to
everybody kind of being like
something is happening we don't know
what should we be scared
i want to just quickly clarify i said
walking plasma balls are called talking
plasma balls
and i think that might be part of what
these people are seeing so wait wait
what is that it's when you focus lasers
from like at least three or more base
stations into a point in the air
and then it creates like a ball of
plasma that reads on radar and they
think that it's a craft because they can
move it around really fast and they're
like no craft can move at this speed
because they're just
pointing a light but do you think our
military wouldn't know that
if they yeah they might know it it's
crazy it's almost i think their gas
is gaslighting the right word i think
that they're they're prepping us for
some sort of like military they want us
to fund the military fund the military
be afraid
oh interesting that's a very good
perspective but then it doesn't explain
why so many people
for so many years especially after world
war ii started saying that they were
seeing
you know spacecrafts and seeing things
in the middle of the night especially
i i i'm the most amazed by crop circles
like this is like inexplicable like
perfect measurements
circles you know a bit hit in the middle
of nowhere in the middle of the night
couldn't possibly be they say it was
just a prank and they cover it up
i mean there's just been a lot of
questions and the government never
answers it you know and i
i definitely of course there's always
some sort of initiative to get more
money from
its citizens but i've always just
thought that they know a lot more than
they're ever telling us of course
because they're the government
and it's too much when it happens all
over the world it stops being conspiracy
right so it's one thing to say
okay my grandmother saw this thing alien
spacecraft and she said a green man came
out and you could be like alright
whatever your grandmother she's probably
crazy
cool but there was also a story and this
one is
to me the most striking and you can fact
check me on the country i'm pretty sure
it's zimbabwe
um but there was like 51 school children
that were playing on the playground and
they all ran inside
and they said they were crying and they
were terrified and the teachers were
inside correcting work i think it was 65
exactly 65 school children
and they all said they described a
spacecraft that landed
and this was almost like 30 years ago um
and that a little person came out and
was looking at them but didn't say
anything but they knew what the person
was saying or the
alien whatever it was wanted them to
think in their heads they didn't need to
move their mouth to communicate
and so this happened and obviously it
made a big splash around
the world and so harvard actually flew
in
psychiatrists and psychologists into
this
random place in zimbabwe and sat down
with the kids to determine whether or
not this was a hoax right and so they
isolated the kids and they spoke to each
of the kids and you can actually watch
the interviews of these
children so young and they all kind of
look terrified and
they describe what they saw and he had
them draw pictures and he's
interviewing them and asking them so how
did it make you feel you know
it made me feel scared you know they're
all talking about it and he concluded at
the end of it that there was no way that
this was a hoax because it's impossible
for that many children to lie
um and tell the same story and we all
know that like you know kids they just
like they don't have that kind of a
memory they're not nefarious they can't
all tell the same story
and the most interesting thing about
that despite harvard coming in into
africa including that they told the
truth is that now they're all adults
and they did an update interview with
them and they all
say that's exactly what happened on the
day that's what happened you know in
that schoolyard that day and
we don't have any explanation for it
other than did you know that since the
lockdowns
ufo sightings paranormal activity has
been has been going up reports of people
saying unexplained things have been
happening yeah
it's it's weird i mean it's just weird
stuff and to me
you know on the topic of aliens i've met
people and they're just like there's no
way it exists and
define alien okay just i mean any i
guess being that we're not aware of when
you say alien you don't have to say it
has to
have big eyes or whatever but i always
found it really strange
it really had to apply a little bit of
common sense that we're obviously not
the most intelligent being otherwise we
would be like you know hey
tim let's go to mars tomorrow real quick
you know grab something
come back let's go i don't know just fly
up and
look at all the planets and we can't do
that and not even that aliens could be
at the bottom of the ocean right we
can't even get to the bottom of the
ocean so
it to me it's weird that there are some
people that go it's just impossible
because
the government hasn't told us or we
haven't seen it with our own two eyes we
didn't even have cell phones my dad had
a beeper
when i was growing up and think about
how much tech has changed it's like
we're definitely not the smartest beings
but we're also definitively the most
arrogant beings because so many people
are convinced that we are the smartest
being so
i guess we get one point for being super
arrogant i i bet we're actually fairly
stupid
um what i mean by that is we can collect
data
we like we'll watch a rock roll on the
ground and go oh and then figure out how
to make a wheel
but that's like the lowest level of
figuring out how to invent something
right
so if we can assume that there's other
intelligent life in the universe
then they're intelligent the likelihood
that there is a more intelligent
species than us is probably animals some
of them
think about some of the instincts that
animals have like you know dogs i mean
just they they have powers and things
that we don't really comprehend
as human beings like so as again we are
definitively i'm not saying that dogs
are the smartest i guess you could say
well they don't live in houses and they
don't have air conditioning and all this
stuff okay sure
but they definitely have you know a
different sense than human beings have
and people don't explore that at all
which i've always found to be really
weird they're foxes that are like tuned
into the magnetic
uh compass of earth so they can like aim
magnetic north when they hunt
and then they'll like dive on their prey
that's under the snow
the incredible wolves i mean i love
animals learning about weird things that
animals can do i'm like they're almost
alien yeah sharks
can sense electromagnetic energy with
their nose i think
you you were mentioning your gra was
your grandma told the story about yeah
little green man or whatever
a lot of people probably think something
like that's really crazy but uh
let me pull up the story we got a few
stories that are resurfacing now because
of this uh ufo report
these are legitimate sources this is
armytimes.com i assure you this is news
guard certified
92.5 out of 100. army chief talks
little green men and sets off you and
ufo enthusiasts
they claim there's an explanation for
this but here's the quote
they say this is mark milley who's now
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
you'll be dealing with terrorists you'll
be dealing with hybrid armies
you'll be dealing with little green men
you'll be dealing with tribes
you're going to be dealing with it all
and you're going to be dealing with it
simultaneously milly said
now of course here is the right wait
what was that did milly just say cadets
will be battling little green men
and then they go no no no they just mean
that there are some countries that have
people
in the military who are small and they
wear green outfits
so that's what they mean by little green
men and hybrid didn't mean
like human alien hybrids it
it means something i don't know not
chimera
yeah i mean you just i think for a lot
of people like they just don't
like to apply their brains at all they
just they're more comfortable
believing whatever it is they're told
right i mean just like i always say to
somebody it's like going back
100 years and trying to explain the
concept of a cell phone to a human being
like it just could never happen like you
can't just like pick up the phone and
call someone and like you know
and have them be on the other end no
matter where you are in what country i
mean like they're they just can't get
their minds around it until it's
physically in their hands
and so people's you know are just not
ready to
even think about it a lot of times and
i'm the exact opposite where like i want
to hear
everything because i don't i think you
it if anything else it challenges you to
think critically
right and it's such an important
exercise to constantly
be trying to bend your mind like a
pretzel right
yeah i love the idea of infinity trying
to just understand it
that was a really really good point
about cell phones though imagine going
to the 90s
and saying within you know
it's what iphone came out 2007. if you
said within 10 or so years
you will have a device that can record
videos take photos
you touch it to control it it can give
you access to the summation of human
knowledge
to a certain degree you can communicate
with other people you can make phone
calls on it they'd be like get out of
here yeah
in 10 in in 10 or 15 years even
even when regular cell phones came out
like the nokia candy bar
if you explained a modern you know like
galaxy 21 or whatever they'd be like no
way well forget that like playing
playstation think about trying to
explain
electricity to people that were using
lanterns to like to light their homes
like when jd rockefeller and like
that we know how he garnered his wealth
you know like oh we got gasoline and now
we've got lanterns and this is going to
power your home imagine trying to
explain to those people
the concept of electricity power in the
world right they would think you were a
tin foil had a conspiracy theorist and
you would be on the outskirts of society
because you're crazy and actually
interesting little historical tidbit
when um
who was it uh uh not jd rockefeller
the other one of the big guys warburg uh
electricity
it was thomas edison but who funded him
it was a bank
back jp morgan yeah i'm like couldn't
couldn't guess jp morgan do you know
what happened with the first time he
uh thomas edison lit you know the first
one that was ever lit with electricity
do you know whose home it was
no jp morgan's right so he invites a
small crowd of wealthy people to come in
um and he shows them they come in so
everything's obviously lit by lanterns
and he turns on his house
and they're like oh my gosh this is
amazing and do you wanna know what his
father said to him afterwards he said
this is crazy
this will never power the world don't
invest in this any further this is stuff
that belongs in the circus
just jp morgan's dad jp morgan's dad
it's the first the first showing of
electricity was in that house
right so it's just it's you have to
think about history to kind of consider
the present
and we still have these people that
think this could never happen
and and yet it takes the conspiracy
theorists
you know of their time to really push
the world forward
i think they'd say zeus shot lightning
bolts i think he had electricity
yeah right have you heard of the baghdad
battery it's this ancient battery it's a
clay pot you fill it with vinegar and it
has a
an iron rod in it and then you wrap it
with copper wire and it produces an
electrical charge and they make like
50 of them and line them all up and
connect them all to each other and so
like in the pyramids there's no fire
marks because they didn't use fire to
light when they were in their building
apparently they used theoretically
hypothetically as electricity so light
they had
big batteries there's a hieroglyph of
this guy holding this big what looks
like a tube of
like an inc with like a filament in it
and then like a slave is like holding
the battery behind him or something
well that's actually funny because
there's this whole concept now i'm very
into mythology
like you know greek mythology and i
think there's something
um eternal about the lessons that you
learn when you study mythology but
what's interesting is if you consider a
lot of mythology
and you think of them you know even if
you think of egyptian uh hieroglyphics
and stories they tell
the concepts of their aliens could
literally just be like a person from
2021.
have you ever watched stargate sg1 which
is crazy they would have been like this
person's a god
oh my gosh this person just made life if
the person told them they were a god
then it would reinforce it would
reinforce it you you want to watch
stargate sg1
yeah that's basically what it's about
yeah right so they find this portal that
can open up with different codes to a
bunch of different planets
and there's an alien race that was
claiming to be gods
and they just had better technology so
these people are like yeah
they're gods and they're just it's magic
it's it's technology i think about like
the angels and the demons from the bible
and how they could fly and had wings i
think they had hang gliders
[Laughter]
swooping in with their i don't know what
dropping dropping fire
little or jedi flaming oil on people and
stuff yeah
jet packs maybe that's the crazy thing
too like when you talk about cell phones
is that
when people tried to predict the future
you look at what what was that what was
that movie
um uh where where where sylvester
stallone goes to the future and
everyone's ultra whoa time cop
i i'm so bad at movies it's the one
where
the seashells we just talked about no no
no no
the chat's gonna light up they're like
dude yeah how do you not
remember the name sylvester stallone in
the future yeah he gets frozen
and then uh bag that sounds like he goes
to picture wesley snipes is the bad guy
i know exactly what you're talking about
i can't remember the name of it
i've never seen it but anyway like they
try to predict the future and they
couldn't fathom cell phones
so like he walks up to us demolition man
there we go he walks up to a pay phone
and it's a video pay phone and that was
like the thing that
they thought in the 90s in the future
the pay phones will have cameras and
it's like bro we just
technically yeah in our pockets yeah
that's so funny yeah people
but people don't think like that it's
interesting i'm i'm always fascinated by
what the human
human mind is willing to comprehend like
what other technologies are we
thinking are going to be centralized
that are going to be decentralized in
the future
yeah that's a great question energy
production
maybe we have batteries but like you
can't power like uh
there's there's stuff for a while now
there's been research into
uh materials that when you walk they
fight it causes a vibration
electricity and it generates a current
yeah so you could literally have a phone
that just charges because you're walking
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you